which of you is better at chess i mean
let's do it this way can you
um andrea can you say
what is
in which way is alex stronger than you
which way is she weaker than you not
physically in in terms of the ch in
terms of chess
um
well yes of course she is higher rated
but when we do play
um i think her strengths against me
where she really gets me is the end game
she has stronger end game so she can
and i actually have a stronger opening
um but as soon as she said i'm supposed
to say what is good about you not you
yeah i'm getting there well see this is
the same because don't worry it's
related okay because if i can i can get
an advantage in the beginning of the
game but as soon as she starts trading
pieces down like my confidence drops
because i know that the end game is the
hardest part of the game and the longest
and that's where she ends up beating me
so her end game is her
i think really what makes a difference
and she sounds like her psychological
warfare is better too because if you're
getting nervous
that is that it's harder to play against
higher rated players same how you know
magnus and former world championship
champions have that psychological edge
so i think it's always going to be
different for andrea because she knows
statistically she should be winning
something like one in four games but she
usually does better than that because
she's very distracting and talks a lot
that does help what does it feel like to
play a higher rated player
what's the experience of that
in like uh
playing somebody like magnus
so it depends on how much higher rated
than you they are if it's someone who's
like between me and andrea let's say
it's a 200 point difference
you know they should win but at least
you still feel like you have a chance i
was playing in title tuesday which is
this tournament chess.com has every
tuesday and i got really lucky beat a gm
drew an international master and then i
got paired against hikaru nakamura and
my brain just went blank because the i
just know that i'm so unlikely to win
that i couldn't even play the game
properly when it's that much of a
difference where they should be winning
like 99 of the time
but that's like psychological so you're
saying that's the biggest experience
it's like
actually knowing the numbers and
statistically thinking there's no way i
can win but i meant like is there a
suffocating feeling like positionally
you feel like you're constantly
under attack
you just feel like you're slowly getting
outsmarted and the worst is when you
don't even know what you're doing wrong
you come out of that you're like
i thought i was doing great and i got
slowly squeezed i didn't understand what
was going on and you're just kind of
baffled it's kind of like watching alpha
zero beat up stockfish and you don't
really understand why it's making
certain moves or how it thought of the
plan you just see it slowly getting the
position better and that's what it feels
like i i would add
it's kind of different for me if they're
someone who's significantly higher rated
so let's say more than like 300 points
or you're playing magnus
what i notice is i just feel lost
straight as soon as i don't know my
preparation because they know so many
opening lines that they're gonna know
the best line to beat you that you
haven't studied so then on move 10
you're like he already has a maybe plus
0.5 advantage which is really small but
for someone with such a significant
skill level you know you're already lost
at that point and it's like a third of
the game
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
andrea
andrea is very good at opening
preparations as she said as she said she
likes bringing that up i mean she's very
meticulous about it where she'll really
go in and learn her lines
um and having that initial starting
confidence isn't just helpful for the
opening but it helps develop your plans
for the middle game so i think she's
very good at that
um i think she's actually pretty good at
tactical
combinations um what is tactics tactics
is like solving puzzles
um we're basically finding lines that
are forced where if you find them you're
going to win
so that's like puzzles within a
position yeah exactly whereas strategic
chess is making slow moves and over the
process of like 20 moves you get a
slightly better position based on
understanding of the overall strategy
you